make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so it's been a little while since
we made a video on too powerful for
Marvel movies um because we got caught
up in Avengers in game and spider-man
far from home I regret nothing
do those those those movies like I'm so
excited for spider-man far from home I
am so hyped you have no idea and like
Avengers in game I am sooo like that
that I look at that movie and I'm like
yep I am still like super hyped about
that movie because it was so awesome
right it was like too close to the face
I'm curious what the future of the MCU
is gonna look like right you know like
after we get into like after we finished
fight a man far from home for like five
years
we're basically gonna get sequels the
only exception is like the Eternals
movie and like Adam warlock and
guardians of the galaxy 3 and and the
like the Eternals I'm excited for right
like Icarus and I'll do like the fulcrum
near the fulcrum like I really hope they
they bring him in I don't know if they
will cuz the fulcrum is so ambiguous
that's what we've never really done a
video people ask me all the time can you
do a video on the fulcrum I'm like
there's really nothing to do I mean I
guess we can but it's like there's
really nothing to do because like
there's one point in in Neil Gaiman's
Eternals when like I think it was either
Icarus or like one of the Celestials or
somebody but like they approached they
approached like the fulcrum and they
were like so what are you and the
fulcrum is like a little bit of this a
little bit of that and this is kind of
like okay it's like that doesn't really
answer anything all the leaves it like
super ambiguous whatever the fulcrum is
like you just super powerful it's widely
accepted the fulcrum is just like an
aspect of the one above all um I don't
really know where people got that from
but it's I think you just kind of kind
of assumed to be the case I have a read
Neil Gaiman's eternals in a long time so
maybe it's covered in there I read it
when the first came out back in like
2008 I think it was um but I haven't
read it like 11 years so I don't really
remember but in this video we're
covering the molecule and we're talking
like one of the molecule man is too
powerful for Marvel movies but there is
a way to defeat him but before we get
into that here's the thing so I was hit
up by it by a guy named Jeremy Scott I
don't know if you guys know where I
guess the folks of Jeremy Scott and I
don't know if you know who Jeremy Scott
is but he's the co-creator and narrator
of cinema sense right it's always just
like
and like I'm I love sentiment since
their be hilarious that they made a
video it's like everything wrong with
comics explained in like 10 minutes or
less and it's like I don't have this
guy's voice that would be amazing
that'd be hilarious the cinemasins did
that like everything wrong with Commerce
explain I would laugh in that video like
I would have a good time watching it um
but nonetheless they hit me up because
because you're me Scott's writing a book
called Able's Wheatley she wrote a book
called the evil right and like it's on
sale in Amazon I'll post a link down in
the description this isn't really even a
brand deal right like I'm not really
being paid you know or anything like
that
but they hit me up and said hey like
you're like like one of the biggest kind
of of youtubers in the world and like we
would really love for you to be able to
like tell people about this so that any
kind of reach a larger audience so the
whole idea behind this is that it's it's
there's there's a school for kids who
have powers right but like that in and
of itself isn't super unique what makes
it unique and interesting is the nature
of the kids right because like they're
basically kids with disabilities but but
what what you have is like a kid named
James for example um who is blind but he
can teleport and so it's just kinda like
okay like how does a person with that
sort of of makeup make use of its powers
right like how can a person teleport if
they can't see and it was someone like
Nightcrawler for example like like as
long as he's been to a place he can
usually teleport there or at the very
least you know understands the nature of
it why like he can pick up a picture of
the Eiffel Tower
despite having never been there and then
teleport there right I mean you know
what whatever really answers the
question is it possible for teleport for
Nightcrawler like teleport into somebody
else but I digress the overall theme
behind the movie is cool all right I'm
sorry behind the book is cool because
what it does is it takes these kids who
have disabilities and of course there's
the overarching theme of like a central
enemy that they kind of have to face off
against but they also deal with these
like being bullied by other kids and so
on and so forth it's a pretty cool
concept the idea is it's a young adult
book right so it's not we're not talking
about like the Iliad
where's gonna be like a zillion pages
long oh it's cool like it's it like I'm
getting it like I don't know it's like
50 bucks it's like I'm gonna buy it this
is a pretty solid book but I really sit
looks like it'll be a pretty solid book
so um so didn't even like I like I want
to throw that out there so you guys know
that it's there
and when it's when it comes out like
you'll be on the lookout for cuz I'm
gonna buy it
I'm like I'm gonna check it out but uh
but but ok so talk about the molecule
man Oh agrees here's the thing like the
molecule man is interesting when it
comes to when it comes to Marvel Comics
and the reason why is because he's not
like most villains not even in terms of
personality but in terms of his powers
right so so the molecule man like his
name is amiss no one you can do pretty
much anything right I mean like their
deeds it'd be better to call him like
the atom man like like okay here's a
really cool example of the fight between
the molecule man and and dr. Manhattan
would probably be a stalemate because
they can both pretty much do the same
thing control matter on the atomic level
um the cool thing about this is that
when it when it came to molecule man
when you look at most villains I take
for example magneto magneto pops up and
he's got control over magnetism well I
mean there's not a it's not really like
I have more control over magnetism it's
control of our magnetism Magneto's
powers haven't really grown in scope so
much as they've become more nuanced
right as he's been able to realize he
can do more more finite and I guess not
really more fun that more nuanced and
fundamental things by controlling his
powers over certain aspects than he did
when like you first popped up so I mean
like but it has kind of grown in scope
to a degree in terms of the effect he
has on earth but with regards to like
using his power he's like them trolling
the iron inside of a person's body and
different things like that uh when you
look at someone like Owen Reese it's not
necessarily that way it was really his
power is just kind of like expanding but
because of himself right so the way this
played out his molecule man was
originally this guy who had just kind of
worked in a place called Acme labs right
I mean yes that was kind of a throwaway
name that you saw kind of a hand waving
name like Acme labs you know just some
fill in the blank company and he was
working on some wild experiment or
something like that
and any event the spirit the experiment
went awry and like he was just kind of
Zach Wright ended up with these crazy
looking scars on his face and so
following that he ended up becoming a
villain and he carried this wand
everywhere he went like this is old
Stanley Jack Kirby storytelling right so
we carry this wand everywhere he went
and used it to like you know manipulate
matter on a localized space like he
controlled a teapot or like a teacup or
he would like change something small
into something else and he was for the
most part the way he was
build by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby he was
a minor villain right he wasn't like dr.
doom level in terms of his power he was
just kind of a minor villain and the
Fantastic Four fought him and they
defeated him quite readily actually you
know in what was essentially quick fast
and in a hurry um and he kind of stayed
that way for a while right like he was
never significant in fact there was one
point where he died and then came back
to life because his essence existed
inside of his wand or something weird
like that
um but all that changed in secret Wars
in 1984 and the reason why was because
at the time the story the way it was
told by Jim shooter was to kind of like
fill up all these characters and make
him grandiose and awesome and all that
kind of cool stuff and the molecule man
was a character who had just kind of
been hand wavy and thrown away and
nobody had ever really done anything
with him and so he was a minor villain
nobody really cared about that like just
like Jim shooter could do anything with
and so what ends up happening in this
story is is that dr. doom ends up
approaching the molecule man and I think
it's when Doctor Doom has the powers of
the beyond or I can't we'll talk about
that here in a second and I think it's
when he hasn't powers at the honor but
whatever the case is he basically ends
up talking to the molecule man Owen
Reese and says hey man I don't know if
you know but like you could be God you
just don't know it and this is kind of
like what are you talking about and it's
like well the way your powers work is
that you control matter on the atomic
scale like you don't need a wand like
you don't like you don't need that I
mean it makes you it makes it makes you
look like a goof like running around
with a wand you know and pointing into
people and you don't doing doing you
know spells the other it'll it makes you
look silly man like like you have this
insane amount of power the problem is
your confidence that you don't believe
in yourself now you don't believe that
you can really do anything well you
believe like your inept you're incapable
and the world doesn't the world can't do
anything for you or you can't do
anything for the world
and he says but like remove those mental
blocks get some confidence in your life
and then like you'll become insanely
powerful and I think that happened
because he got laid I don't member off
top my head but regardless of the
circumstance the mental blocks were
removed from like the molecule man's
mind and like he became so opie it was
it was crazy how powerful he was this
guy could do anything and when I say
anything I mean anything like this guy
could run up on Wolverine and turn the
adamantium in his bones to like to like
skittles if he wanted to he could do
anything like it was insane like the
amount of power he had
was was wild in scope and in fact it
really came to a head with the Beyonder
well it's like the two kind of went hand
in hand and we talked about this in the
Beyonder video that we did before so so
the way this worked is that you have
what's you have like the multi which
right this multiversal space you this
this circle that I'm making you know
there's universes all throughout this
this circle and they're all just
different universes the ultimate
universe to me and Marvel Universe the
Marvel Cinematic Universe assuming that
any of what Mephisto is saying was
basically lies from what the TV spot
spider-man far from home but whatever
the case is you have like this this
circle which contains this multiverse
and then you have everything outside of
it and everything outside of this
multiverse is called the beyond which
rule not necessarily everything there's
kind of a space out there you have like
other world places like that but
regardless do you have this huge expanse
of space outside the multiverse called
the beyond first and inside the beyond
verse are the beyonders they're
basically just the super omnipotent
wildly powerful beings how they come
into existence
we don't really know all we know is that
they were just there one day and the
power these guys possess is short only
to the one about all right like they can
kill it they can they're more powerful
than everyone except for the one above
all they're the only thing is the only
being they can't outright destroy and we
know that from Jonathan Hickman Avengers
of New Avengers right like they
destroyed all the cosmic entities in
every single universe they came across
all the Celestials like every version of
Galactus and the Living Tribunal and
seemingly all at the same time right I
mean it was it was like Hank Pym
floating from space and he was like you
know I saw this battle taking place
across the entire multiverse at the same
time and they were killing every cosmic
entity everywhere and of course the
Living Tribunal shows up to try to stop
them and they destroy the Living
Tribunal and that's the end of that and
it's just like wow so so so what what
what hitman did to kind of tie in to the
original seeker wars is what he said is
the Beyonder at that point in time back
in 1984 where the original Secret Wars
came out was a child unit basically he
was it was a little kid and so the way
this played out in the original story
anyway is that that molecule man was
working on his experiment he was zapped
with his powers whatever whether he was
that by whatever happening and what he
had done is he had accidentally opened
up a hole to the beyond verse right
which has been done multiple times
that's how you create cosmic cubes in
Marvel Comics and so so we'd opened up a
portal to the beyond verse and a half
the energy that was supposed to go into
a cosmic
you went into him and the other half
ended up just kind of floating out into
you know the universe and then basically
like kind of coalesced and grew from
what was essentially like a fetus into a
child and that's where the original
beyonder came from and so so like with
these two guys they were basically equal
in power and the Beyonder was not so
they both beyond Ramallah come and
whatnots like to give you perspective
because they were equal in power we can
kind of use the example of one as an
indication of the other but the way this
happened was like when the original
Beyonder you know when Secret Wars on TV
for in bed and then Secret Wars 2 picked
up the Beyonder came to earth because he
was just kind of curious about you know
what was going on and how things
unfolded and like like there comes a
point where like he kills mistress death
but he kills death in the universe and
like the Living Tribunal and a man and a
handful of others end up showing
everything like hey you got to do
something about this like they go to
molecule man like yeah do something
about this because like we can't stop
this guy this guy is just way too
powerful and so the fight between the
molecule man and and in the Beyonder
like literally has these shockwaves that
are like felt throughout the entire
multiverse it's crazy how powerful they
are but the long and short of it is that
what you're talking about is a guy who
can basically do anything he wants
across the entire multiverse who in his
classic version was more powerful than
the Living Tribunal now why do I make
that sort of clarification because what
we ended up getting was this unofficial
secret wars 3 story there was written in
the Fantastic Four and the way this the
way this kind of played out is it
explained the whole nature behind why
molecule man exists right so like the
things I mentioned about him absorbing
part of the power of a cosmic cube and
so on and so forth
that was all explained in in the the
Fantastic Four story and so it ended up
being that like him like the like the
molecule man and the Beyonder were
merged into a single cosmic cube and
then eventually the Beyonder came back
but when he did his powers were far less
than they were before so it was a way
just kind of reduce his powers and scale
and reduces powers in scope that's why
if you go and you read stories where
like this century for example I think
kills the molecule man then like yeah I
think what I think was in siege when
that happened but this century kills the
molecule man yeah I mean you killed him
in that story because that's the deep
Howard version of molecule man that we
saw after the story of the Fantastic
Four
if it was like 1984 1985 1986 and 87
version of molecule man that never would
have never
would have happened like like the
century would have gone to attack
molecule man he wouldn't just waved his
hand and turn him until like a box of
Snickers and that would have been hit
like that that like they would have been
done like dunzo like that would have
been the end of the fight
um but nonetheless in terms of like
translating that character to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the cool thing about
that is molecule man in his most
powerful form is way too powerful for
the MCU but in his either his his really
even like this post powerful form right
like I mean cuz II was still pretty nuts
you know like when you get in like
Hitman's fantastic hit Ben's Avengers
New Avengers and so on he's still pretty
powerful in his own right but if you go
back to like his original version right
like when he first popped up well then
he can easily be defeated because he
didn't know what he was capable of right
so like imagine if Thor didn't know he
was worthy and he didn't know how strong
he was and he believed he was just a
doctor named Donald Blake who could
benchpress like a thousand pounds and he
thought that was really it like imagine
like if the Avengers showed up and
fought that guy if he doesn't know how
powerful he is there's no reason to
believe that he thinks he can beat them
now it may be the fight kind of you know
goes on in such a way where Thor begins
to realize how powerful he is and this
essentially learns how to fight while
he's fighting and then overpowers the
Avengers which is the most likely
scenario but in this case Owen Reese had
mental blocks in his mind right he could
not get past he couldn't get out of his
own way he could not get out you know
could not gain any measure of confidence
and so what that meant was that he was
easily defeated you take that version of
male to a man you throw in the MCU yeah
he's a one-off villain or he's a villain
you can bring back a couple times or
kind of extrapolate and expand on them
and have them learn how powerfully as as
time goes on right like dr. doom stone
into the MCU and then dr. doom tells
molecule man hey you're basically and
like you're basically God uh go be God
and then of course you end up getting a
crazy powerful version of himself but um
but yeah I mean there's there's a couple
different ways that can go but using the
original version of himself is really
the best way to put him in the MCU if
you don't want him to be too Opie
because it offers an out it offers a way
for the Avengers to basically defeat him
and to call it a day but let me know
what you guys think I mean if you guys
were to see the molecule man in a Marvel
Cinematic Universe
uh which one like like how would you
want to see him it's like the super Opie
version or like the more tamed down less
powerful version or like his original
form where he was basically kind of a
goof and look
that's silly let me know you guys think
I'm kind of curious you know what what
what stance you guys are not taking but
with that being said we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to come this explain make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
rock floor if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and
remember I know more than you do I'm
just kidding what a crappy thing to say
oh no no just make sure you guys hit the
sub button and yeah I will catch you all
later
[Music]